[Music]
were these mayors pretending
when they cut police spending yep they
slashed police budgets but their own
protection they decided to fudge it
this one's gonna piss you off too
according to a new report from forbes
magazine
don't miss their this year's swimsuit
issue joey the cover has stewart varney
and the thong
mayors and other officials in roughly 20
cities around the country defunded
police while spending millions on
security details for themselves in their
defense it's gotten really dangerous
lately
the one thing these cities have in
common they're all being run into the
ground by democratic mayors a non-profit
group filed freedom of information act
requests and found
which city of offices had police details
and how much it costs
some low lights in chicago home of
murder
the city spent 3.4 million for 22
officers last year to guard
unnamed city officials baltimore spent
3.6 million
for 14 cops to cover the mayor the
state's attorney and the police
commissioner
and in sf the sp the city spent 2.6
million last year to protect mayor
london breed
so she's protected but of course the
stores aren't here's two dudes
casually walking out of a tj maxx in la
with arms full of crap
it looks like they're boarding a flight
if they got any more relaxed you'd have
to carry them
as well and why not a new law makes
thefts
below 950 bucks worth of stuff a
misdemeanor instead of a felony
so it seems california is now number one
in america for theft
here's the human hairstyle gavin newsom
today on his crumbling state
there are some people that say some of
the policies championed by democrats
like prop 47 others
are making crime worse what do you say
to that well the evidence doesn't back
it up the last three decades we've
actually seen a significant decline in
crime in the state you're seeing crime
increase in red states
that had no criminal justice reform
commensurate with the crime rates
that we're seeing here in california
something tells me if you stop
considering crimes worth pursuing of
course you're going to have a documented
decline in crime
because you're not documenting it the
fact is there's there's more substance
in that guy's hair than what's
underneath it yes
emily do these mayors and leaders
deserve security if they deny it for
others
no you guys in seattle
mayor durkin she has two two details
that protect her
the the a uniform division and then
whatever sort of comes with being a
mayor she's a 7.5
million dollar house and here's the
thing of that uniformed detail
the the regular officers of seattle the
police department in the precinct if one
calls in sick or calls out
they prioritize her detail still they
won't take away cops from that so it
leaves that the actual precinct the
actual precinct and protection of
citizens
even more lean and understaffed than
defunding already does
and my favorite quote because there's no
cell service up there in her
neighborhood apparently and there's no
bathroom
so one one cop said literally and i
quote you just sit there and stare and
think about how
your life is for four or five hours end
quote
so then the resident socialist psycho of
our city council
the swant she led a protest up to the
mayor's house chanting about how they
need even more communism there in the
city
so then it got real and the mayor came
out called it a riot and then they sued
each other so it was like this crazy
infighting
because yes when it comes to their front
door is only when the mayor's protest
and
final point i just have to say that adam
and jeffsky is the guy behind
like finding all this stuff out and he's
constantly exposing
the government's payments and everything
the payroll and all the numbers
everywhere that our tax dollars go and
that's the level of transparency that we
will never unfortunately get from that
white domed
mausoleum i feel like i just watched an
episode of real housewives of seattle
yes right i got one chuckle out of that
i think our audience is on drugs well i
gotta chuckle because she pretty much
described my entire bodyguard career
spent a lot of time staring in the
rearview mirror going you were better
than this
yeah you're watching someone else live
their life
and that's what you're doing yes there's
a moment where you throw someone down
the stairs and
yes there's a moment when you get to
beat people up for the most part though
it's
you staring in a mirror going i
had a plan but the movie the movie it's
like being in the marine corps but the
movie
my body but what's up yeah that's not
real no one sleeps with the bodyguard
unless they're really mentally destroyed
patty hearst married her bodyguard yeah
they all the yeah they all do
they all do not the jobs i got so snoop
didn't fall in love with you no snoop
didn't fall in love with me neither did
boss lady
guard who buddy klum did right okay the
point of the show is not to
not to
[Laughter]
as far as i'm concerned you're the only
one
no one ever fell in love with a
bodyguard job except kevin costner and
he's
kevin costner who wouldn't fall in love
with him it's true he is gorgeous
and you were all racist for calling me
out on
obviously my issue with never being
loved as a bodyguard
shame on you all joey um
you said you're going to run for
president this is a great example of why
it's great to be a politician because
you can't run sorry you get elected
to become immune from the laws you enact
you're just trying to hold it together
aren't you like it's falling apart
this is me running right now like i'm
running there i am that's all the
running i got in me
and uh i missed that question so i'll
just
yeah just say what you want to say let's
get to the c
block that's my second big word i was i
had a third one now i don't forgot it
listen this goes right back to the to
the previous argument rules for thee not
for me
you know don't we'll take away your guns
we'll take away your freedom we'll make
you wear a mask we'll take away your
money and give it to somebody else
but don't try to apply those rules to me
right but at the end of the day
you know you get what you ask for if the
if the new rule is 950 bucks i mean like
it's a gallon of milk less than 950
bucks in california anymore like
that's going to be the the result is
everything's going to be priced
above this arbitrary threshold that
these idiots
in california have created shoplifting
inflation
it's going to be a new financial term
you're going to think that dod's buying
everything
all the toilets are not hundred dollars
no needs protection though i think they
should use that money and help protect
those
elderly asian women yes did you see that
on canal street saturday 10 30 in the
morning guy goes and
pushes this she's gonna die if the asian
mom who's in a coma is probably never
going to wake up yeah
she mugged in a subway 10 30 in the
morning using that 23 million dollars to
protect them still haven't caught the
guy
every one of them a pistol i'm sorry
yeah say that on tv that's what i
believe that's
that's the second amendment every one of
them should have the right an
opportunity
to carry a firearm in an armed society
is a polite society
i don't want anyone to get shot but if
somebody has to get shot
let it be the people who try to kill an
elderly person for no good reason yeah
and by and i'm not joking the guys
guys still out there hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else